bang-bang what's up everyone lunch money
time a wall she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get her lunch
money right
Here I am with the beautiful intelligent
plain Tamara Nova she looks like Santa
Claus today with the all red outfit on
what's up so how are you tell the people
what you want to do to my hair so I'm no
longer beautiful before we get into the
news breaking news breaking news plane
and I were speaking this morning and she
was telling me how she needed a haircut
and so me being the generous kind loving
gentleman that I am I said no problem I
could do that for you and there's been
lots of women I think that on the
internet have been talking about cutting
their boyfriends her husband's or maybe
brothers hair but I figured I haven't
really seen that many guys say hey look
I gotta cut her hair so newsflash I
tweeted if the tweak is 10000 like she
said I can do it
you know that I will live stream it if
we get to ten thousand lights Internet
go do your magic he was trying to say he
was trying to make me do it for a
thousand likes I was like really
so ten thousand seemed like an
impossible number and then I got a
couple hundred likes in the first ten
minutes so we'll let you know all right
what's going on with unemployment
[Laughter]
let's go live stream what's going this
isn't a live for the ninth week in a row
millions of Americans have filed for
unemployment benefits
another 2.4 million Americans filed for
the first time last week we're almost at
40 million we're at thirty eight point
six million people in nine weeks we're
gonna hit 40 million it's absolutely
devastating to give you an idea that
about 155 million Americans that are
considered in the labor force we are
gonna hit 40 million probably in the
next week or two and it's just sad but
guess what the solutions simple open up
the economy get people back to work more
than 50 percent of all deaths are
happening in nursing homes lock them
down
the old the sick the people with
pre-existing conditions the death rate
for young healthy people is very low
open up the damn economy and you can go
back to work safely no but it's it's
just common sense we made the decisions
that we made to lock down the economy
based on the data we had at the time
that was a smart decision we overreacted
to make sure that we didn't get a bunch
of people killed that was a good
decision we now have more data we now
understand this better open up the
economy get people back to work have
them wear masks tell them to wash their
hands tell them to do social distancing
but get businesses back on line because
you're gonna have 40 million Americans
that lost their jobs
40 million people have lost their jobs
meanwhile those Starbucks US same-store
sales have recovered more than 60
percent from last year
how's that possible dead cat bounce is
coming I don't like the dead cat bounce
why I just don't like the same so part
of this is that this is a very
misleading headline 60 percent it's not
60 percent growth basically think of it
as they did $100 right let's use these
numbers $100 last year at this time now
they're doing $60 don't you surprised if
you like you should be lower than that
no they've lost 40% there still have
they're down 40% that is a massive thing
a normal recession you would see 30 40
50 percent lost this was such an outlier
in terms of they went from having
revenue to zero yeah right because of
the government mandated shutdown so now
all we're gonna hear for the next couple
of weeks is a recovery recovery recovery
the only numbers that matter the only
number go back to the pre pandemic
levels how far down is the academic
activity and right now they're at a net
40 percent loss that would have been the
bottom of the 2008 crisis right so it's
just we're gonna see a lot of
intellectual Olympics we're gonna see a
lot of what is known as a chart crime
you know what chart - chart crimes are
things where like they show the X and
y-axis but they don't label them so it
just looks like this but you don't know
it what's the unit of the unit of
measurement that they're using
with a time horizon whatever they just
show these charts that look really bad
but they don't actually put anything on
it or they'll do things like I can show
you a hundred percent growth yeah but
then it's from $1 to $2 yeah right it's
just a chart crime don't do chart crimes
on Twitter what do you think about you
what do you think about Starbucks okay I
don't know where we did it we were just
Starbucks today I do my part the
Starbucks was interesting today because
normally you know you order on the app
and you just go pick it up from the
storefront thing they have today there
was a line and the people behind me were
actually asking if they could pay with
like cash or a credit card because it
used to be mobile only
so one I've never seen a line and - I
guess Starbucks is now kind of opening
up a little bit more with so you don't
have to just do mobile yeah so you can
pay on the spot how long until they just
say open the stores back up whenever New
York's shelter-in-place order North
Carolina's shelter in place just got
expended five weeks five weeks that's at
the end of June these people have lost
their minds all right
well some bankers so a lot of bankers
are really excited to go back to work go
to their high-rises but a lot of banks
are saying no no we made that the future
may not look as it did before
and I just want to say I was reading
this article and then I stumbled upon
JPMorgan Chase said it might station
attendants outside elevators to help
push buttons so fewer workers need to
touch the keypad that is not a good
solution why
you're gonna have somebody who's literal
job will be to be a button push pusher
elevator button question yeah but they
probably Bob on hey the protective sauce
if there's there's elevator there's
elevators who have elevator attendants
that literally they sit the elevator all
then these go up and down I think that's
an unusual form of what is it a form of
unusual torture crime no punishment yeah
right long Bitcoin short the bank and
while we're well while she's trying to
get rich the rest of us trying to get
our lunch money
right so if the bankers go back or they
don't the world will keep spinning it's
not a big deal
but I do think that this is a sign of
things to come where there will be a
change the way that people work in
offices but I have a question so all
these people saying you know high-rises
are over because you can't have more
than two people an elevator at the same
time all this stuff andreessen horowitz
investing today and another remote work
startup are we kind of over rotating to
this work from home world where converse
isn't gonna be here forever
hopefully so one day we'll be able to be
in person again like why is all of this
happening all at once assuming we'll
never be allowed to be in person again I
think so it's a great question there's a
couple of trends that were already
underway that have not been accelerated
so tech companies over the last couple
of years here realized wait a second
there's technology that now can allow us
to work in different areas right and it
still works of remote work there was a
lot of companies who just said look
we're never going to try that that won't
work for us but they were forced to try
it and they're like wait a second
actually wasn't as bad as we thought it
was that was easier than we thought it
was so you'll see some of that happen to
his societies is psychologically
changing where it might have been weird
to like work from home people
well well banker or any industry right
but really banking it probably more than
any that person is are they taking the
day off and actually doing anything
right now I think it's getting kind of
intertwined in society a little bit more
and people are becoming more open to
that idea and then the third thing
frankly is like now people I think are
realizing wait a second like why do we
all shuffle into these big high-rise
buildings right and spend commute like
commute times forty-five minutes an hour
I want to have there's people who come
from Connecticut or New Jersey into New
York to end that commute like is that
really a good use of time right but I
just I think it can be done so much more
efficiently if you're in personally last
night I was on FaceTime with two of my
friends all of a sudden I got like
kicked out of the room and then I got
back in I could see them and I could
hear them but they couldn't see or hear
me so they were just talking to each
other and I was like oh my god guys I
felt like a ghost just like hey and
nobody could see me or hear me and I
feel like that period of time it's just
so inefficient you lose
a lot of time just when you're a person
is just so much easier ladies and
gentlemen this is a perfect example of a
user error but like part of it is yes of
course there's technical issues my
favorite is when people are on zoom' and
they're like hey uh hey rich uh you're
on mute you're on mute you're on you
like and they played this game right or
like people get on it and they're
looking like this on the screen like can
you see me can you see me but like I
mean obviously there's like that type of
stuff that goes on and yes there's tons
of benefit to going in person to do
certain things but there's also a lot of
things that you don't need a beach
person so it's not as binary and I don't
think that they're gonna take bankers or
any industry and say hey you don't ever
have to come to the office instead what
I think they're gonna say is you are
encouraged or you are eligible to work
from home more often so to take this one
step further what is gonna happen to the
high-rises in New York City what will
they be used for if they're not used for
work
I think commercial real estate in New
York City is going to go through a very
big change there will be two major
factors of that there will be a
repricing of the market the question is
how deep is that repricing or how far
two prices fall into how long does that
last right remember real estate prices
were at an all-time high within the last
like three years in New York I think but
they over built right so one of the big
things was there was tons of
international investment in New York
City real estate whether it's commercial
or residential so builders like oh the
goal is capital flowing in building
isn't like writing software you got a
building construction it takes time for
projects whatever so they started to
ramp up all of this production of
buildings and then while that was
happening the international investment
kind of started to fall so there was a
mismatch and so now all of a sudden
there's all this built-up infrastructure
in New York but there's not the demand
to actually take it out right in terms
of renting buying etc so there there's a
oversupply which means prices will have
to readjust how long does that last we
don't know and the second thing is OB
reuses so how many retail places are
gonna end up being used for something
else how many of these old you know
high-rise buildings head office space
like you might go in and say hey I want
to make something for the profile here
right but it's not this
like a traditional commercial real
estate space anymore you just use it for
something else interesting would you go
and take out a high-rise and make it
like the profile Empire sure yeah make
it into a hair salon baby speaking of we
go have a conversation actually Rent the
Runway what's going on there Rent the
Runway so they're about to raise new
food they're trying to raise new funding
25 million except the new funding would
value the company below its previous
billion dollar valuation and a seven and
seven hundred and fifty million dollars
so that's a down round so there's a
couple of ways I think about this though
one yes it is a down round they raised
at a billion last time now they're gonna
750 but the economics of the business
has changed right and what I mean by
that is it's like in the public stock
market right when United Airlines stock
fell from $80 to 20 every wasn't oh my
god it's so cheap right right kind of
but the financial performance changed
right so they did eight billion dollars
in revenue last year now if the market
caps five billion you would say why is
it trading at a lower valuation than
they did in revenue well it's because
they're not gonna do eight billion
dollars you're so used to in the private
market seeing things just go up
evaluations go up that when something
goes down or stays flat you're like oh
that's only because we were in the
longest bull market in history over the
last ten years and so most people who
are let's call it 35 or younger that's
all they've ever known right right they
were just coming out of college in the
great financial crisis and so pretty
much their working career has been a
bull market they don't see this type of
stuff it is interesting though broadly
speaking to see how the startup scene
shakes out with all these companies who
had never been through a recession
before and only there were a lot of them
were founded in the bull market so we'll
see how that goes you have Rent the
Runway I need pause to rent the runway
for I'm going on my third month pause
now but they've been really good about
just letting people pause instead of
saying you know I'm just gonna leave as
a customer they're letting you pause
your membership so you don't have to pay
the monthly fee until you want like how
many people in New York City do you
think did that a lot of people a lot
right so their financial performance
I bet you the 750 million dollar round
is actually a very high valuation based
on what they're projecting their
financials to be for 2020 right so like
yes they're taking the 25 percent
haircut on the valuation but based on
their revenue if you just looked at it
from the revenue for 2020 they're
actually getting a massive valuation
because the hope is that people will
come back you'll continue to die on the
bright side at least you know they can
raise money yeah true and from like
legit yeah right all right what's going
on with college cheating so the college
cheating scandal remember when all the
celebrity parents and a lot of non
celebrity parents got in trouble for
getting their kids into colleges Lori
Loughlin a full house and her husband
will plead guilty in the college mission
scandal and they're pleading hold on one
second
they're both pleading guilty I agreed to
plead guilty to one count of conspiracy
to commit wire and mail fraud and that
means that's they're gonna she will
spend two months in prison pay 150 K
fine and be subjected to two years of
supervised release and perform a hundred
hours of community service and he's
going for five months gonna pay a
$250,000 fine two years of supervised
release in 250 okay why is he getting so
much more than her maybe he was the
mastermind that sounds kind of sexist
what why is he getting I didn't read the
internet on that one so I can't comment
but well I'm just here to ask the
questions but what is very interesting
is do you actually think they should
serve jail time
I don't like elitist ISM elitism yeah
yeah and I don't think that's fair and I
really operate on things being fair or
not anything that's absurd but how many
people what percentage of people do you
think lie on college applications
my guess over 50% a lie in what way and
anything from Oh like how many community
like volunteer time you did and how many
people put on their college application
that they were in a club and they went
to one meeting I know but this is but
this is more of like this is wait worse
this is much
intentionally but my point is it's bad
they shouldn't have done this they
should be punished but when you put it
in context of that entire process is
super corrupt and the incentives lead
the people to to do dumb things right
and send false information the way you
solve this is like yes you should punish
these people this is obviously they're
doing it in a way to like discourage
other people from from doing the same
thing right that's what like change the
process right I think this kind of stuff
is always gonna exist though right like
I went to a school I remember when we
were in high school we do a school no
interest fall and so I just remember
people being like well I'm a legacy so I
can you know my brother went here my
sister went here my dad don't need an X
amount of money and I'm like oh I can't
check that box it sucks
I agree but like do those people really
do you want to hang your hat on that
what like if you if you wake up if you
wake up every day and you're just like
I'm doing X Y or Z because somebody else
donated money here or whatever like but
the shitty thing is that I don't think a
lot of these kids knew that their
parents were doing this come on you
don't know that your parents are saying
you're the punter on the football team
and you don't even know what a football
is come on you're saying that your
parents said hey you're gonna go out for
the rowing team and you're like I've
never even been in a boat before don't
know come on okay can we move on you
just you're so nice to people what do
you mean it's called the truth okay the
kids go to jail oh that's a real
question big question if the kids
participate what if they didn't well I'm
here to ask the questions I don't know
if the kids participated or not it's
very interesting know how this is being
treated because they are influenced by
their parents who have the money to do
that you are a kid your top says you're
a little kid it doesn't matter who and
your life tells you to do dumb things
don't do dumb things if it's your
parents soul different have your parents
ever asked you to do
something bad that you said no I have my
dad one time told me to go knock over my
brother when he was little and I was
like now I'm not gonna do that you just
did it voluntarily now I went knocked
over my other brother okay so there's a
college girl who has you on musk says
old phone number and every time he's in
the news her phone explodes with like
texts and calls but the funniest part is
like she's a 25 year old skin care
consultant and she got a lot of calls
and text messages asking for Ilan so she
asked her mom like hey keep getting
these texts about Ilan I don't know who
that is and her mom's jaw just dropped
and so there's some really interesting
things that people have texted her like
she has accidentally intercepted oh wait
no one woman volunteered to go to space
space with SpaceX another person sent a
blueprint for a bionic limb a South
African businessman asked about buying a
thousand trucks the IRS called about a
complicated tax issue and she has all
the text right here it's such a good
story guys does she respond she does and
at one point like the former Walt Disney
executive John Lasseter texted her about
the test like he bought said it was a
Magnus magnificent car and she got to
talk to him and it was a funny story oh
yeah if I was this lady I literally
would respond to everybody and say hey
Eli's not available right now
but if you send your name your title
your corporation and a way to be
reaching I'll make sure that somebody
gets back to you and then just reach out
and say hey I'm available but you got a
job she says whenever I see Miss mean
pop in the news I'm like okay I have to
actually learn about what he said
because chances are so it's gonna
message me about it or call me about it
I mean it's pretty cool what would you
do I'd be saying Wilde's I'd be sending
them all kinds of crazy stuff be like
sorry I can't talk right now I'm getting
on the spaceship yeah or I'd be like
hold on a second texting you back from
my neural link in my brain like whatever
and then they'd be like it's like this
isn't Elon and I'd somehow like find a
selfie of him on the Internet
somewhere and send it back and be like
yes it is no I just be a troll is not I
just would literally just be a troll
that's fine we're at a zero we're at
zero time but before before we let you
guys go oh yeah in 32 minutes we have
880 likes on the tweet if it gets 10,000
[Music]
you know I would look good we we could
do that I know somebody who could do
that if we get to 10,000 likes on the
tweet I will absolutely livestream me
cutting plane as hair as you can imagine
I have skills I have humor I have a
computer it'll be well I made for the
Internet where the scissors where the
scissors well I tend to go and grab the
ones that are with the with the knives
we got like a little wood thing with the
knives and then their scissors and every
time I grab them clean it could
literally plate it could literally be in
another state and she calls me because I
know you just picked up those scissors
don't use those scissors and what's the
point having scissors and you can never
use this for cooking use them to like
break open boxes and cut my hair what
why does it matter because we have to we
have two pairs of scissors one that I'm
allowed to use and one that I'm not a
lot just don't know where they are I
don't need to know I know whether one of
them is why would I need to know where
all the scissors are I know where one is
it's been a true pleasure how many likes
what we have to get for me to be able to
shave my name into your head literally
you do not have enough likes on Twitter
or like Twitter doesn't have enough
don't challenge you don't challenge the
internet no no don't challenge your
number out there ten thousand ten
thousand fifteen like eight hundred
thousand million that's not a number all
right you're doing Bulgarian math no
problem alright guys that's it for today
appreciate you watching lunch money well
while she's China
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get a lunch
money right we will see you guys
tomorrow hopeful
polina still has the hair on her head